- And another thing, wait,
I have to say this though,
side note, is you, another
thing that's been going on
while you're at home is snacks, right?
You're really into pretty random snacks.
- I can't stop eating.
I don't know what's gotten into me.
I think it's kind of being
home in the quarantine.
I usually eat really
healthy when I'm on tour
and you know how this is,
I was on tour for six years
and all I was eating was like
grilled chicken breast
and rice and spinach,
and sometimes green room gummy bears.
But I,
(laughing)
since I've been home I've
had time to experiment
with different snacks and
I take it pretty seriously.
Yeah.
- I love it.
Well, maybe you can explain
some of these snacks
you've tweeted about.
This one is "Dry Oreos are so weird to me.
"Need dunkage," which I totally get.
I have to, I like a cookie
soaked, I'm with you.
I'm like, "Let's just soak
it a little bit," yep.
- I can't eat 'em dry.
I don't know, I don't understand
people who eat Oreos dry.
They also have to be double-stuffed.
That's a rule for me.
And sometimes I like to
smear peanut butter on them,
which is an old trick I learned
from watching "The Parent
Trap" when I was a young child.
- Yes, oh my gosh, I love that movie.
Also, I would really love your metabolism.
(laughs)
Like, wait, what?
She's like, Double-stuffed."
I'm like, "Aaah," okay.
What's your latest snack obsession?
- I started making Rice Krispie treats,
but without the Rice Krispies.
And I know that doesn't make any sense,
but I'm make 'em with other cereals,
so like Fruity Pebble treats
or like Cinnamon Toast Crunch treats
and they're so easy to
make and they're so good.